saying no can be very empowering because
it asserts what we want or what we don't
want
but saying no can also help us better
understand ourselves our values our
personal policies and our rules
my name is Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
[Music]
today I'm really excited to speak with
Vanessa Patrick Vanessa is associate
dean of research and professor of
marketing at the Bauer College of
Business at the University of Houston
her research focuses on the pursuit of
pleasure and how we can avoid the lure
of pleasure Vanessa recently released a
new book entitled The Power of saying no
the new science of how to say no that
puts you in charge of your life Welcome
Vanessa so excited to have you here and
to have our conversation thanks Matt I'm
delighted to be here and super excited
to share insights in my book well let's
get started
on this podcast we've done a few
episodes where we have explored
improvisation and communication as you
and our listeners know perhaps the most
important and famous rule in
improvisation is to say yes and yet
you've written a book all about saying
no can you share the importance of
saying no and what it can do for us
absolutely
it is I believe very very important for
all of us to say no to the things that
get in the way of us living our best
possible life you think it is important
for us to recognize the trade-offs that
we have to make every time we make a
decision when we say yes to something we
are saying no to something else the way
I see it is in some situations we want
to grow the conversation and engage in a
constructive dialogue with the other
person for example when we are
brainstorming or when we are conducting
some sort of idea generation at work or
even when we are talking to our kids in
those situations we want to use the
Improv rule the yes Andrew
in other situations where we want to say
no we are better off keeping it very
short and very concise in those
situations we do not want to enable the
conversation we want to convey our
stance and we want to communicate that
stance effectively so it sounds like we
need to just be balanced in our approach
that there are times where yes and
really can help us and then there are
times where being very definitive in
certain in saying no can help us as well
now isn't it true that at times saying
no can have negative results doing so
can damage existing relationships
prevent new ones from developing and
have lasting consequences are there ways
to say no that avoid these negative
consequences you know the simple
two-letter word no is really daunting
for a lot of people for the reasons that
you outline people are super anxious
about saying no because they are
concerned about damaging relationships
with the ass and calming their own
reputation
the solution I also in my book is
empowered refusal
I coined the storm of empowered refusal
to describe a way of saying no that
stems from your identity and gives voice
to your values priorities preferences
and beliefs when we say an empowered no
I know is about us not a rejection of
the other person so for example in our
research we recommend that we use
empowered language that implicates our
identity like using the words I don't
when you say I don't eat chocolate cake
or I don't take phone calls between six
and eight in the evening because that's
family time
it comes across as much more empowered
it's easier to say no and you're more
persuasive in contrast using the
disempowered I can't I can't eat
chocolate cake I can't take a call
between six and eight in the evening
almost begs the question why and invites
pushback from the asker
and this might result in you saying yes
when you actually want to say no I find
this notion of empowered refusal really
interesting because it's one vehicle
through which we can claim and publicly
State our values and I appreciate you
giving some very specific guidance in
terms of word choice so don't is
different than can't and that helps us
be definitive helps us set clear
boundaries and reduces the likelihood of
pushback so that's very useful you've
shared some ideas about verbal things we
can say to to be empowered in our saying
no are there non-verbal components as
well things we do with our body and
voice that can also help us say no
effective communication of course is the
information that we convey using both
our words which is the content of the
communication as well as our non-verbal
cues the manner and the style in which
we fee so of course we talked about
empowered language just a minute ago
where we talked about using what I call
in the book standing upwards words like
I don't I never I always which convey
conviction and determination but when
you couple those words with an empowered
stance your body language also needs to
convey that level of empowerment in fact
it's very hard to say I don't eat
chocolate cake and come across as
disempowered in your body language
another effective way to communicate a
refusal while maintaining the
relationship with the asker is to use
positive body language cues to secure
that relationship with a genuine smile
or leaning forward or a kind gesture so
while your words are communicating that
hey I'm saying no to you it is not a
rejection of the other person but just
giving voice to what you believe in and
what you care about I really think that
distinction you just made is very
important saying no does not mean you're
rejecting another person saying no means
you're standing up for something that
you believe in and having congruent
non-verbal behaviors help support the
relational message while also explaining
or demonstrating the value message
things like being big in body posture
being open making good eye contacts
smiling all of that can be helpful and
we need to be mindful both of the words
we use and the way we say them so thank
you for that reminder and for the clear
examples
your book not only makes the case for
empowered refusal but you also provide a
toolkit to help us develop and hone this
skill can you define the competencies
that make up your art art framework
yes I outlined three competencies for
the art of empowered refusal art stands
for awareness rules not decisions and
totality of cell
I propose that the first competency that
we need to invest in if we want to
become more effective in saying no is
deep in self-awareness to invest in
self-awareness helps us sift between the
good for me activities and the not good
for me activities and helps us decide
what to say yes to and what to say note
the second competency is to make rules
not decisions based on that
self-knowledge so once we have the
self-knowledge and can identify what we
care about what we believe in what we
stand for it helps us to make simple
rules that guide our actions and
decisions when we lean on what I call
personal policies that we can establish
to communicate our no response we
move from being frazzled and frustrated
when someone makes an Ask of us to be
much more calm and choosy and empowered
and we come across with much more
conviction and determination
we recently had an episode where we
talked about creating your own personal
Manifesto in a lot of the key points
there were to find your values and what
you stand for and I hear the first step
of the first competency that you
advocate for is doing something very
similar I'm curious about these personal
policies that you talk about because I
think it's one thing to understand your
values it's another thing to set up
rules and policies that help you live
those values can you share with me an
example perhaps of a rule or a policy
that you use in your life or you've seen
others use absolutely so a personal
policies are these simple rules that
give voice to your values and priorities
and preferences and beliefs so for
example a personal policy would be every
time I take my first sip of coffee in
the morning I just stopped and I'm
grateful for the day it's a small
meditative moment that I have just
incorporated into my daily life to just
be grateful for everything good that's
happening and that's a ritual so I
divide personal policies into different
types but this is a ritual you could
also have decision so I have a firm
decision role that I do not take red eye
slides I do not function very well the
next when I take a red eye slide because
I don't sleep very well on claims and so
having a personal policy in place which
says I don't take red eye slides really
helps make the decision about when to
take a flight so these are shortcuts
that we can put in place that just ease
the way we make our decisions but also
lead us to be happier and enhance
well-being in the long run
I can see how these would help reinforce
the ability or make it easier actually
to say no when you have these rules in
place you've thought about them you
understand why they exist because
they're in alignment with your values
and so when one of these situations
comes up where in essence you're being
tested or challenged you say no just
because I have that rule so for example
in working with my children I have a
rule you don't drive the car after a
certain time of day even if you ask and
so it's helpful to make it easier for
you I appreciate that and I definitely
have spent some time creating my own
personal Manifesto thinking about my
values I think I need to take the next
step as you've advocated to find those
policies and practices that follow from
that so thank you
so you know Vanessa I find this notion
of personal policies and rules really
fascinating especially since they come
from the values that we've thought
through do you have any further advice
or guidance on these personal policies
so personal policies are different from
boundaries and it's really important to
make that distinction because boundaries
are like the barbed wire that we put up
to protect ourselves from outside forces
invading on our territory personal
policies are different because what
personal policies are these pretty red
ropes which are actually called
stanchions that you see in the Trader
Joe's or in a movie theater that you set
up for yourself that help guide your
decisions and actions in the way that
you want to go and that are aligned with
your values and priorities and I think
that this very powerful to reframe what
we care about and what we want in terms
of personal policies instead of
boundaries then we become much less
reactive and much more true to our own
self one of the things I'm taking away
from that and the visualization is
really powerful those nice red ropes
that guide people in a certain direction
versus the barbed wire fences and in a
boundary sounds sounds defensive whereas
these policies sound more
forward-thinking and momentum based so
very helpful thank you so let's imagine
that I've mastered the art of saying no
I feel empowered in the refusals that I
do what advice do you have for managing
the potential pushback or ostracizing
that might result so when my children
want to drive the car after the rule
that I have how do I deal with that
pushback
I think the beauty of empowered refusal
is that because it is based on your
identity it's easier to withstand that
external pressure and stay a steadfast
and strong
now unfortunately we will come across
people who will not take no for an
answer and we have to deal with those
pushy ass skirts and so in the book I
talk about a bunch of strategies that
you can deal with pushy ass guys one
that I think is pretty handy is to use
technology as a buffer so for example
research shows that we are 33 times more
likely to say yes
to a face-to-face request
so if you are getting pushback from a
pushy ass and a face-to-face request you
might choose to convert that
conversation to digitally mediated
conversation you know sending no by
email is much easier than repeating your
no face to face sometimes all it takes
is an emoji with a thumbs down sign and
that communicates a no more than word
scan and so I think that leading on
technology to help us you know reinforce
our position and say no can be super
interesting and important
I'm shocked by that statistic I know
personally for me it's definitely hard
when the person's standing right across
from me but 33 times is a lot and I
think your idea of putting some distance
between you maybe through technology Etc
can really reduce that I certainly feel
more comfortable with a refusal that is
virtual than one that is in person so I
appreciate that advice so I want to get
very personal here your model helps us
say no to others but does it help say no
to ourselves for example you've talked
about having no rule to chocolate cake I
struggled with a no rule to chocolate
chip cookies or wanting to listen to one
more podcast episode are there ways that
we can help say no to ourselves yes
absolutely in a research study that I
published in the Journal of consumer
research with Michael Henrik Hagrid we
studied how empowered diffuser can be
used as an effective way to
self-regulate so in a similar way that I
don't Works in communicating an
effective no to others it also works as
effective self-talk by implicating our
identity we cure ourselves feeling that
we believe in certain things and when we
hear ourselves talking with empowerment
we buy into that and are more likely to
resist Temptations like chocolate cake
chocolate cookies or that one extra
podcast
so the self-talk we have allows us to
reinforce and reaffirm our values and
beliefs and can lead us to therefore be
stronger in tempting situations very
interesting I'd absolutely need to
practice that my waistline will benefit
from it and my sleep as well you talked
a little bit about your research so I'd
like to change the subject and a while
back you and a few of your colleagues
did some research on how to transition
from strategy forming to strategy
implementing and one of the topics that
people are really interested on this
podcast is is about strategy how do we
formulate strategy and then how do we
execute on strategy so I'm curious what
did your research suggest and what role
does communication play in going from
formation to implementing that's a great
question there is a huge body in
research as you know that talks about
the difficulty that teams have with the
transition from planning to
implementation and the implementation
failures that result
liquor research however focuses on how
to best navigate the transition between
strategy and implementation so our
research helps identify a set of six
leadership nudges that Aid in crossing
the scasm
we based our research on the idea that
planning is inherently more pleasurable
than implementation and so we identify
two broad sets of nudges the first set
of nudges are nudges that improve our
will barge to be able to transition from
planning to implementation and the
second are the decrease in the desire to
continue planning and create excitement
instead on implementation now throughout
the paper we talked about the importance
of communication being able to use these
insights to be able to get people in
their teams to shift from the planning
board to the implementation more one of
the ways in which you can do this is to
be able to figure out how to convert
your vision to your action with your
teams and to do that by creating these
very strong and compelling learning
outcomes and so focusing on using
communication to focus on outcomes help
speaker people switch gears and helps
them move from a planning mode to an
implementation
the other thing that is really exciting
and which I also talk about in the book
is the switch from using verbs to nouns
so there's research that shows that when
you ask doctors to vote and you give
them a badge which says I am a voter
which basically talks about your
identity and who you are and talk about
you in terms of using nouns you're more
likely to vote however if you give that
same badge to people with the words I
wrote I voted
it focuses on a verb and it's less
likely to result in action
so many things there to unpack so
first we need to nudge people out of
their planning mindset and get them into
an execution mindset and it sounds like
we can do that in many ways including
getting them excited about very specific
outcomes the language we use and we
talked about this with Jonah Berger this
notion of turning verbs into nouns so
instead of voting we are a voter and
that can help and helping people
understand
that their actions can help achieve
these outcomes can motivate people in
that direction very very important a lot
of people spend a lot of time planning
and not really planning to execute on
the strategy so that's very helpful
so before we end I'd like to ask you the
same three questions I ask everyone who
joins me are you up for that absolutely
all right so question number one if you
were to capture the best communication
advice you ever received as a five to
seven word presentation slide title what
would it be leave a place better than
you found
I believe my mother has told me that for
for years and years tell me more why is
that important for you
I think that statement embodies so much
as it comes to Communications that you
enter a communication with positivity
and with the willingness to share and to
be true to yourself but also to create
value for The Listener and so when you
engage fully with your whole cells and
you appeal to both the heart and the
mind of The Listener you do leave a
place better when you found it
I love it and I love it because of
everything you said but also because it
forces you to think about what it is
you're doing and saying and it helps you
to see that you need to be audience
Centric and focused to help make it a
better outcome a better environment as a
result of your communication many of us
can become very self-focused and focus
on our message and not so much the
outcome of that message
good advice I like that
question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why
so I admire many many
communicators but one that I deeply
Admire from more recent times is a woman
called Melody Hobson
Melody is the president and co-ceo of
aerial Investments which is a black
owned mutual fund and investment
management firm melody was named by
magazines 100 most influential people in
the world and it not only does her
content matter and she speaks on really
important topics on financial decision
making financial literacy and financial
inclusion but she does so in a way that
is so powerful and so passionate and so
memorable she speaks through your head
because she's talking about really
really important financial information
but she does so with stories and with
really heartfelt emotions and strong
belief that makes it an amazing
communication
wow I'm definitely going to listen in on
some of her communication it sounds like
one of the things that really drives and
motivates you to listen to her is her
ability to connect through story and
communicate complex financial
information
final question question number three
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe as a marketing Professor I do
think about this quite a bit and I think
that there are three main things that I
would find out one is
authenticity and trustworthiness
second is the ability to communicate or
appeal to both The Head and the Heart I
think that effective communication is a
combination of both rational elements as
well as emotional elements
and the third is to really focus on the
listener to create value in your
communication such that you have left
the dialogue better than you found it
and I'm going to cheat and say one more
which is admire because I think by
smiling when you communicate not only do
you look warm and caring and engaged but
you even sound that way which I think is
super important in all communication
I like that your three ingredients
combine both
how we say something through our smile
it has us thinking about our audience
but it also has us thinking about our
content both the rational and the
emotional components to build that
authenticity and trust that you speak
about so that those ingredients are
going to combine certainly to an
effective communication recipe
Vanessa this has been fantastic thank
you I have no regrets about our
conversation about saying no and it
really helped me to think through my own
personal priorities that I have in
personal policy so I appreciate that
thank you for being here and I wish you
great success with your new book The
Power of saying no the new science of
how to say no that puts you in charge of
your life thank you thank you Matt it
was my pleasure
[Applause]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn